ta conscience une dernière des très
grandes stars françaises tu n'en avoir
trois ou quatre comme toi voilà c'est à
toi tu en as conscience de ça ou pas du
tout non j'arrête tu t'en fous de ça non
je m'en fous pas non je suis content que
les gens m'aiment bien ouais mais te
dire que j'ai conscience d'être comme tu
as écrit à immense non je dis quoi alors
bah tu dis rien tu dis un pote un copain
un artiste tu vois je suis je suis pas
j'ai pas la tronche au comme ça c'est
vrai oh là ça a dégonflé il y a
longtemps tu as eu la tronche à maman
une petite heure
qu'est-ce qui t'a fait redescendre ton
entourage tu es quoi c'est non c'est moi
non mais c'est vrai
pourquoi parce que j'ai jamais fait de
plan ouais si tu veux quand j'entends
qu'on me raconte ma vie toi par exemple
que tu racontes mon histoire avant de
temps en temps pas tout le temps mais
raconte beaucoup ça me fait marrer parce
que en fait j'ai pas choisi un truc j'ai
pas j'ai un plan je devenir un grand
chanteur un acteur un ce que tu veux non
ça c'est fait comme ça tu sais je suis
Fugain m'a balancé dans dans la rivière
j'ai suivi le courant j'ai pas mis les
bras en croix pour l'arrêter j'ai fait
ce que font les Chinois j'ai chevauché
le tigre hein voilà c'est tout ouais
je vais faire ci je vais faire ça je
vais hein t'es jamais dit moi je vais
faire ça je vais être chanteur je vais
faire ça
j'ai suivi ma vie et les chansons tu les
as choisi comment c'est toi voilà ça
c'est moi qui moi qui en avait l'idée
alors je les ai pas toutes faites tout
seul j'avais de très bon très bons très
bon co-auteur et on discutait à table ça
vous avez des repas et chacun balancé
son idée tu vois
et après on écrivait ensemble et Michel
et je vois dans vos chansons je vois que
vous êtes hyper fort en géographie quand
même oui ça je suis pas
franchement Africa
ça fait quel bac ça fait quel bac
[Applaudissements]
c'était obligé ma question c'est après
philo et histoire que tu es un monstre
vraiment c'est vrai alors je le sais
voilà je vous dis Michel voilà il sait
que je suis fan absolu je vous le dis
même dans mon immeuble on était dans
l'ascenseur ensemble parfois je n'osais
pas lui dire que j'allais au trois
arrête-moi où tu veux mais vraiment je
suis très heureux qu'il soit là ce soir
je sais que Mathieu aussi alors j'ai une
petite anecdote mais toute petite mais
comment vous étiez jeune chanteur vous
avez loué un appartement au ski dans une
petite station qui s'appelle Vars les
clos et c'était à ma grand-mère et vous
étiez jeune où ça tu dis que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans les Alpes du Sud
vous voulez l'appartement et vous avez
dit vous faites quoi dans la vie vous
avez je suis chanteur vous dites pas
connu elle vous dit mais est-ce que vous
avez de l'argent pour payer
l'appartement et vous avez dit oui
alors ça tu vois ouais ça s'appelle une
légende urbaine
j'ai jamais été dans les Alpes du Sud
toujours je quitterai bien je m'étais
moniteur j'étais en Savoie voilà
quelqu'un d'autre
Michel tu en as fait des duos aussi ça
m'a fait tu as fait beaucoup de duos
Johnny Hallyday Céline Dion Aznavour
je suis pas un fou des duos ah ouais
comme moi j'aime pas quand on co-anime
parce que non mais parce que surtout du
haut homme femme ah ouais parce que
c'est pas les mêmes tessitures du tout
donc un qui est obligé de baisser
l'autre de monter tu connais pas
forcément la chanson de ton pote à fond
suffisamment à fond alors j'en fais j'en
ai fait je fais avec Céline avec Johnny
je vais Goldman j'ai fait avec plein de
gens avec
comment il s'appelle
préparé la chanson pour nous c'est ça
c'était pas tu viens dans un chaud
chante-moi une chanson avec lui par
exemple
avec lui non tu as des jeunes chanteurs
que tu aimes bien les nouveaux chanteurs
avec qui tu aimerais
collaborer ou pas du tout tu en as pas
franchement je veux dire des conneries
je les connais pas assez j'écoute pas de
musique pas du tout donc j'écoute du
jazz ou pas Booba tu as déjà écouté non
non jamais non et je pense que ça
n'arrivera pas Jul Jul jamais Jul ok Jul
Jul non non
[Applaudissements]
parce que on parlait de Johnny on a
parlé de Johnny c'est vrai que vous
étiez très très proche et après voilà
tout le monde dit que c'était plus
compliqué etc c'était vraiment compliqué
ou pas du tout vous avez toujours été
non c'est de ma faute j'ai été mal à la
droite
tu sais j'ai
dit une connerie en fait que je ne
pensais pas mal d'ailleurs mais lui par
contre
il a mal pris la connerie c'était sur
ses filles oui j'ai dû connerie mais je
ne pensais pas être méchant du tout du
tout du tout dire je t'ai étonné qui qui
réagissent aussi
aussi sec que ça je dis bah écoute et un
jour je le rencontre
j'écoute je ferai quand même qu'on se
parle il dit je veux pas te parler mais
ça tombe bien tu as qu'à m'écouter puis
après on s'est vu parler tu lui as dit
quoi tu lui as dit je veux que j'avais
fait une connerie que je le regrettais
que je j'avais pas une minute envie de
de comment dire de faire de la peine à
qui que ce soit mais tu sais de
l'improvisation sur scène les mots
précèdent la pensée tu vas tu te lances
tu dis la pizza je suis en train de
faire une connerie tu te rattrapes comme
tu peux mais je me suis mal rattrapé
bref
vachement sympa dans notre métier ah
donc les mecs ils ont mis de la ils ont
mis de l'eau sur le feu de l'huile sur
le feu et
la bande en face on a rajouté un paquet
on dit ouais Sardou
après c'était mort donc voilà on ne voit
plus trop à la télé Michel tu aimes bien
faire de la télé ou pas non ça te fait
chier sinon on a la télé
quand j'ai quelque chose à
véritablement faire tu vois une annonce
à faire un
comment dire faire un show par exemple
les [ __ ]
le plus beau le tout premier
avec avec tout le monde on était cinq
et tout le monde chantait alors là il y
avait du haut il y avait tout tu vois il
y avait il y avait toute la famille il y
avait une ambiance formidable et dans la
salle c'était formidable c'était le
premier des Restos du cœur maintenant je
trouve ça un peu barnum ouais on fait
chanter des footballeurs on fait chanter
les des
tu vois c'est plus la même chose c'est
un truc de musique les restos du cœur
ils t'ont demandé de revenir ou pas oui
et mais là je pouvais pas parce que
j'étais en tournée je faisais quand je
faisais le théâtre j'ai jamais refusé de
le faire mais si tu veux je trouve ça
moins sympathique que cette époque là tu
vois où il y a eu un gars qui
épouvantable avec Eddy Mitchell parce
que
comment elle s'appelle
Véronique Sanson décale sur le temps tu
vois
et dis-lui c'est le temps et au fond du
temps l'hôtel des cales ce qui vécut il
est parti au troisième temps au lieu de
partir au premier il est parti en
couille il a chanté en anglais lavabo tu
vois
c'était l'endroit où on disait aux gens
de nez parce que c'est important que
vous donniez c'est du pognon qui va
aller donner à manger aux gens qui n'en
ont pas et on est pris une crise de rire
avec Johnny on est parti pleurer sous la
sous la batterie donc ça a été foutu
les gens ils ont pris pour des malades
alors Michel tu es tiens des personnages
les plus aimés de France et pourtant ont
accusé de tout ouais c'est un truc de
fou dans ma jeunesse apologie de la
colonisation avec le de la chanson le
temps des colonies alors que c'était
lentille c'était je me foutais de la
gueule des anciens avec être une femme
on t'accusé une mise au génie
le rire du sergent t'avait accusé
d'homophobie oui par exemple je te dis
ouais un moment une des polémiques les
plus connues de ta carrière c'est avec
ta chanson je suis pour la peine de mort
et là aussi voilà
ça c'est vrai que ça a été une polémique
aussi c'était une époque tu sais 70 80
90 c'était le comment dire
très maliké c'est-à-dire que j'étais le
seul chanteur qui s'affirmait de droite
mais d'une droite gaulliste tu vois je
sais pas un fou furieux et
tous les autres c'était de gauche alors
évidemment j'en ai pris plein la gueule
et d'un autre côté ça m'a beaucoup servi
que j'en ai pris tellement plein la
gueule alors que je disais pas des
choses graves je sais pas maintenant
j'ai l'impression que tu t'en fous
totalement
[Rires]
Michel Sardou est-ce que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui notre époque aseptisée où on
peut pas dire
c'est vrai
ce siècle j'aime pas du tout mais
qu'est-ce qui vous irrite tout
on a pu aucune liberté
rappelez-vous qu'ils allaient
70-80 on fumait on faisait l'amour on
roulait vite au bout des bois on pouvait
le théâtre marcher les affaires
marchaient maintenant tout est des
réseaux sociaux ridicules ou des gens
s'expriment quelquefois bien mais très
souvent c'est des abrutis
et ça c'est pas rangé depuis hein
l'époque c'est vrai tu la trouves
dégueulasse que j'aime pas dans cette
époque c'est si tu veux des les fausses
certitudes
on fait peur au public on fait peur aux
gens tu vois en ce moment par exemple on
dit attention il va y avoir le président
dit il va falloir se calmer un peu sur
le on va parler tout à l'heure d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
faut supprimer la chasse parce que les
féminicides sont faits avec des calibres
12 faut quand même être con tu vois je
veux dire
après après elle te sort des trucs c'est
les garçons qui polluent plus que les
filles tu vois genre
il y a des abrutis
je veux bien je veux bien la démocratie
tout le monde s'engueule c'est normal
mais il faut quand même être un petit
poil intelligence en ce moment on n'a
pas besoin de faire peur au public bien
sûr on a besoin de lui dire attention
les mecs mesdames aussi ça va être
difficile donc on est entre nous on
n'est pas on n'est pas on se connait pas
bien tiens je connais très bien
on se connaît tous pas bien on a tous
des situations de famille différentes on
a tous plus ou moins de pognon c'est
vrai mais c'est pas parce qu'on va
supprimer
de Monsieur Dugland ou dublu que ça va
réduire la que ça va changer la planète
je suis d'accord il faut pas non plus
s'en servir 18 fois par jour j'ai
complètement con mais
arrêtons les conneries tu sais il y a
une phrase la philosophe dont j'ai
oublié le nom parce que tu m'as en sucre
pendant une heure
Michel dit la phrase je vais trouver le
filet tu vas le trouver tu seras fort
parce qu'il est pas très connu celui-là
la terre n'a pas de poubelle on dit
bague
merci Michel
qui disait rien de ce meurt tout se
transforme bon pourquoi on ne met pas le
pognon pas la voisine surtout toutes
sortes de recyclage tu vois c'est merder
parce qu'ils ont dit voilà que ça allait
parce qu'on va aller en parler tout à
l'heure
on a tous été comme ça moi quand j'étais
jeune quand je vais une belle bagnole je
suis content j'ai [ __ ] j'ai un jour je
verrai peut-être cette journée
ce qu'on a pris une photo de moi avec un
4x4 cet été formidable
[Applaudissements]
et du coup combien
parce que tu as la trouille de Sandrine
Rousseau
non non mais elle est très sympa elle
est très sympa allez très simple on
l'aime bien non non mais
il est beau franchement
c'est des abrutis merci Michel
heureusement que tu es là franchement
vous avez envie de lui dire le prix
alors le prix
voilà
combien ça
non mais il va à combien
le prix de la voiture
et ça vaut 235000 euros
propos la dernière fois comme quoi la
France est un pays de bizarre moi je dis
que j'aime pas ce que j'aime pas ce
chien je prends ma bagnole je reviens de
Normandie pour venir ici ce soir et
c'est parti à 3 jours
et
je vois des flics qui font ça ça
rentre vraiment 130 comme un bébé quoi
tu vois et
et je dis aux flic je dis aux fruits
qu'est-ce que j'avais dit il y a un
homme qui nous a téléphoné parce que
vous exaguez sur sur la route non
il sait pas que quand on a plus de 500
chevaux faut chauffer ces pneus
[Applaudissements]
incroyable
comme ça froid avec 500 Bourgoin
il faut que tu le chauffe un peu les
pieds quand ils sont en équilibre tu y
vas